А це
питання
організаційно-методичних умов
запровадження I
[музика]
у центрі уваги о
ми ходимо саме і коли ми розглянемо
структуру цього середовища а
за
сучасними засобами і
це
дає можливість визначитися
що має бути в
[музика]
о.в.
у
комунікаційному організаційний момент II
Не
приймають в
[музика]
А
це наявність цієї команди
має забезпечити педагогічний супровід і
і обов'язково залучає до такої роботи і
т
[музика]
у
дітей і кому пощастило побувати в
[музика]
у процесі відтворення і побачити д.і.
а для навчання
але забезпечити і
у цьому решта дітей на
презентацію
Я думаю що в
о.в.
ми
побачимо далі
[музика]
Дякую
існує цей інструмент
І працюючи в
і не лише антикварний проводяться
засідання і
[музика]
це
дає можливість побачити і
[музика]
Я тільки
розумію
підтримка 3D
Я працював як вони можуть нам допомагати
педагогічна майстерність і
В адміністрації яка підтримує сприяє
організації і
[музика]
і
ніколи не дуже багато
дуже потрібно наступна зустріч і
проектами
дуже
недовго але просто безпекових результаті
це можливо
тоді
побачите
дивитися так і
[музика]
а
намагатися пояснити чому в
[музика]
у зустрічі проводяться і побачили що це
саме та формами і
[музика]
і
поведінкою але розповідаючи можна що
неможна але сьогодні о
[музика]
у
2002 додаткові ресурси і є необхідними в
у та особливості
індивідуальних і
на
самому початку презентації таким чином
він у
у позитивному такому сенсі А давайте всі
разом з
А на створення цього середовища
експериментальні заклади які брали
участь у
Я кажу таку чудову
технологію методику і
Ви
маєте
дітей і
у
вихователя перебудуватися
плані того щоб а
[музика]